more gridlock in Syria the latest convoy
bringing food and supplies to the civil
war ravaged city of Aleppo is being held
at the syria-turkey border the convoy
had been given clearance to leave Turkey
but did not have the go-ahead to make
delivery Secretary of State John Kerry's
asking his Russian counterpart to
pressure the Syrian government to end
the delay meanwhile in Aleppo Syria's
besieged largest city people are simply
trying to get on with their lives
Elizabeth Palmer is there with the
latest Elizabeth good morning good
morning you know four people trapped in
a war zone the ordinary simple pleasures
of normal life are especially sweet and
nothing says normal on a hot day like a
swimming pool believe it or not right
now on the government controlled side of
the city several of Aleppo swimming
pools are open for business in the
streets people socialize they do odd
jobs even SAS the camera and it all
helps to blot out the violence and the
fear but nothing can disguise the ugly
scar that divides this city between the
government and its armed opposition 13
year old aya el Hassan is giving us a
tour of her neighborhood of ally done
right on the front lawn this curtain
here what's that for good mouse and then
out here is David the snipers just a few
hundred yards away our opposition
fighters who have aimed their weapons at
Syrian army positions deep in this
neighborhood did you lose some friends
in this war criminal fuzzy Fattah yes
I've lost many she says some were killed
by mortars or snipers some just left the
country aya like everyone who lives here
can remember when fellow citizens of
Aleppo lived down that road beyond the
barriers not men with guns what was the
worst time you can remember wasn't scary
little one night she says a mortar
actually landed in our house it was a
concrete apartment like these so a
miracle no one was killed with courage
beyond her years Aya's
her eye on the future no I want my son
pole again she says and at peace and as
for the people on the other side the
opposition side of that sniper shield we
weren't able to meet them because we're
not allowed to cross the line but they
are besieged at the moment by the Syrian
army and are in really desperate straits
they're the ones who are waiting for the
aid that is stuck at the Turkish border
Anthony in vinita Elizabeth Palmer and
Aleppo Syria this morning thank you